hoho how's it going bros my name is
Pippa and welcome to a Christmas edition
of five word stuff online Merry
Christmas
before we begin I'm already wearing a
very nice Christmas sweater but I feel
like I need to slip into something more
sexier how's it going all right
I also have really funny slippers first
item is Sri Racha candy canes yes this
sounds really good I'm excited to try
these okay
so far it tastes like candy
starting to burn
Wow it's really good I really like it
our Joe well I would really eat these
hey Suraj the candy canes
not so bad next item is if you don't
have any friends which you don't if
you're watching me it's a wind-up
high-five so if you ever feel like do
you want to high-five anyone and you
feel like high-fiving yourself it
doesn't do the trick
then this is the product for you this
would run okay let's try it out
oh it walks let's try it almost there
since this is a Christmas edition it's
cold outside you got your phone but you
can you can click on it because your
glove doesn't work
Wow I called Bluetooth talking glove
baby again stop it okay how the how the
hell do these work and you know they
look like regular ugly old gloves but
actually can I use the touchscreen oh
god I have a fingerprint code ok the
touch screen works and when I get a call
hello
Edgar it's your time to shine you've
been a [ __ ] to step aside this is a
Terran Tula outfit for dogs okay there
we go our porch you're so nice to me
this is your punishment for being an
[ __ ] okay let's lose the demon he's
so ugly
hahahahaha he can't walk in it he can't
oh boy oh boy has this been good so far
for the final item we've gone big this
year what did Santa Claus get for us oh
boy oh boy oh this one is heavy oh Jesus
Christ
belly bump ball really bump ball awesome
more stuff to blow up I blown a lot of
[ __ ] in this show so it is not a problem
I'll see you in a couple hours are you
ready
one good - all right
that was spy weird stuff online press
have an amazing Christmas bake some
cookies watch some old good old photo
pie and then stay with your family just
kidding just keep watching pretty pie
that's it for me for now have amazing
Christmas Hanukkah whatever you do I
don't care
but either way thank you both and as
always stay awesome oh my god I hope I
don't [ __ ] my pants ha ha I'm trying
really hard to fart